the fantasy is that this sentence is
anything more than just purely punitive
and completely beyond the range of what
drug offenders get in this district in
this circuit in this country
I know if Ross walked out of that prison
tomorrow they would never law
enforcement would never hear from him
again in fact he would probably go on to
make some contributions to society to
the community I know that part is done
rehabilitation is done but it is about
punishment and making him an example hi
I'm Kurt Loder with reason TV that was
Lynn Albrecht the mother of Ross
Ulbricht the convicted operator of the
Silk Road drug marketplace Russell Birk
was just sentenced to life in prison
without parole and fined more than 183
million dollars
Ross's story and the story of Silk Road
are the focus of a new documentary
called deep web which was written and
directed by Alex winter we talked to him
a little earlier today so I think there
are a lot of people that probably would
like to see you Ross Ulbricht roasted in
Hell but from being a drug dealer but I
think his what he was doing was like a
radical free-market experiment to take
danger out drug transactions how do you
see him just like five or six completely
opposing ideas of who this guy actually
is and that's sort of what the movie is
about there are absolute ideals behind
the Silk Road that are just woven into
it not only from the Judd Pirate Roberts
who ran the Silk Road but from the other
primary vendors and architects and
moderators of the Silk Road who were
very anti drug war very technologically
agile and really believed that
technology could change policy kind of
the lobbied and like work it was similar
to this sort of Napster mentality which
was sure this is beyond the scope of
current law but current law needs to
catch up with us not the other way
around because things need to change and
once you get into drug policy obviously
the implications are much more grave but
also I would say that you know the
stakes are higher on the other so there
may be a greater need to change that one
of the most disturbing aspects of the
case I think is the how did the FBI get
access to the Silk Road servers in
Iceland it looks like they just hacked
their way and
well what do you think I think that that
no matter what the truth turns out to be
maybe it's a hundred percent aboveboard
but the fact remains that we don't have
an answer that's satisfactory and the
reason that that's a problem is that
obviously laws need to be reformed to
handle the digital age obviously search
and seizure laws we saw that with Wiley
versus California with the Supreme Court
and search and seizure on a cell phone
the digital your digital life your
privacy online matters a great deal they
hide this idea that if you have nothing
to hide you're nothing if you're is just
it's absurd frankly of course you have
something to hide it you don't want
people you know spreading your medical
records around your children's
photographs I mean privacy is a is an
inherent part of being a human being so
how law enforcement is allowed to
surveil how the government's allowed to
surveil how law enforcement was allowed
to search and seize American property
these are issues that are very important
and and reform needs to happen what is
this done to Ross's parents linning and
Curt
well it's cost them a fortune that they
don't have there's a way to look at this
entire story with compassion no matter
what you think happened right and that's
kind of the way I've come at it with the
film with Ross I don't know Ross so I
have to look in a more of compassion
than say sympathy cuz I don't have
enough information but you can look at
it with compassion it is no matter how
you fall on the story an immense tragedy
I mean it is it is I think one of the
great tragedies of the digital age and
you know what it's doing to this family
is destroying you know I would argue
that they are very strong thankfully and
they would argue they're not being
destroyed but it is certainly an
enormous ly traumatic continuing
experience for that family on a
financial and an emotional level so you
know it's an immense tragedy there's no
way to look at it in any other way we
caught up with Alex again after the
verdict came down it was really an
extraordinary experience and to watch
you know watch him to get life you know
again I don't know Ross at all but it
was really an emotional thing to witness
what did he what did he say in the court
he apologized for his actions and you
know it was extremely emotional to watch
was the first time we'd heard him talk I
mean he said the essence of his letter
wasn't there was no new information that
came out today but to watch human beings
in the grip of this was pretty
overwhelming emotionally thank you very
much Alex's documentary deep web will be
airing on the epics channel at 8:00 p.m.
this Sunday and for more on this story
log on to a recent com